to this session.
which is on quality attributes.
As is the usual fashion, any queries,
any discussions,
please place them on the chat site.
On the on your chat box, so that we can.
spend some discussing the points on which
you have got queries.
Yep.
Okay.
Yes, good morning to you, that.
So if there's any query whatsoever.
You know,
people put queries after the meeting.
There were some queries there about the
recordings.
I hope there's no issue regarding
recording. If there is,
if somebody reports it to me now,
I will take it up with the technical team.
I assume there should be no issue because
Microsoft...
TEAMS is a fairly stable application and
The only thing that goes wrong sometimes
is I may forget to switch on the
recording, which as you have noted,
I've already started it today. Okay,
thank you, Bharat.
So.
Understanding there are no issues. Okay,
from this week,
we will start having the quizzes. Okay,
yeah, from this session onwards,
I'll be giving you one full week up to
the beginning of the next session.
To attend that quiz,
there'll be 15 questions.
You'll get only 5 minutes to answer them.
So
Please do your preparation in advance
before attempting the quiz.
Don't wait for the last day because you
may have technical issues.
Only redeeming feature is I'll be having
14 quizzes and you'll have to...
Yeah.
No,
at least 13 quizzes I'll definitely have.
I may have additional quiz,
one additional quiz,
13 I'll definitely have,
and you need to appear for any eight.
So you're welcome to use any tool at your
disposal, ChatGPT, Gemini, the works.
You do what you like. But
It is a random assortment of questions.
Not everybody gets the same question,
so your friend who has appeared is not
going to be able to help you.
And, uh...
The next thing is that next Saturday I
will not be taking a class.
I normally don't adjust classes, but...
Yeah, today it is the second session,
and last week we generally discussed the
context of architecture, what it is,
and where it fits in,
and who's an architect,
and there are things like that. Today,
we are going to move forward,
and I had explained.
Room that.
So I had discussed last time that the
coverage in this course is enormous.
It covers so many areas,
but you need to have...
So.
Mm.
There's so many topics that are going to
get covered.
that you have to have an overview of the
subject.
Today I'm going to discuss quality
attributes.
Last class we discussed that the
requirements for any software application.
Maybe functions.
and non-functional.
Some people who know about watermarking
and all may think that the watermarking
on these slides is final. It is not.
In fact,
the watermarking should have been removed.
The watermarking will be done just before
the comprehensive exam,
because in the comprehensive exam,
you will be allowed to use your slides.
Print out.
And the institute will be placing
watermarks on the slides for that purpose.
And every semester,
the watermark is different.
So, you can't use.
The watermark.
faculty member like me who are not aware
that the watermark may be changed have
continued to use the previous watermark.
So the watermark will be applied directly
to the PDF files. So
At present, you will get a PDF file.
It will be uploaded in Taxira in sometime.
But as far as MS TEAMS is concerned,
the moment a lecture starts,
a copy gets deposited in MS TEAMS.
At least for me,
it happens because of the method I
deployed to show the slides.
You will notice that the method I use to
show the slides allows you to go ahead
with watching.
the remaining pages. So while you are,
some of you may get bored with what I'm
talking about, you might find me too slow.
So what you can do is you can just keep
going forward and you can see all the
flights before I flash off so that you
may even have some questions ready by the
time I reach a slide that interests you.
And in any case,
with such a large slide set,
I'm not going to be really covering all
the slides.
I'll be just passing over most of them.
But this will constitute good reading
material for you.
Even those who don't find time to read
books or magazines or the internet will
find adequate material in the slides.
That is the reason why the...
Slides have been made so voluminous.
No, we said their functional requirements,
non-functional requirements,
and we said their constraints.
Non-functional requirements are basically
quality attributes.
How many PPTs do we have to cover for the
semester? We don't have too many people,
so I'm going to allow all of you access
to mics.
And I'm going to allow you access to the
camera. Most of you,
it's too early in the morning to...
be groomed in a condition to feel like
coming on the camera, but well,
camera all the same. I've switched it on.
So, Madhu, I was talking to you.
Yeah, I saw.
It goes this way, yeah, hello, so...
Sorry, sir, I missed the last class.
Yesterday only I have sound through the
Yeah.
recordings and I saw the first PPD.
There was 86 lights. I went through them.
E.
So this is the second.
Very, this time it's one forty-six. OK,
yeah, it looks good. Yeah,
Yeah, yeah,
so I'm just wondering how many PBTX will
be have to cover for this semester.
the total number of pages will go into a
good number.
It'll definitely be over 1000.
And there are 16 PPTs, PPTX files,
just 16 of them.
So when I give you the printout,
I normally give three,
when I give you the PDF,
I'll give you 3 per page.
If you think I should give you 6 per P,
I can do that also.
So that you don't have to take too many
printouts.
Maybe I'll try to give you both of them.
So those of you who have got magnifying
glasses in their eyes,
you can use the six-page version.
And people who don't mind taking a larger.
..
Bundler printouts can use the.
to read.
So if you're a good printer and you can
get a sharp printer,
you can probably use 6 to a page also.
So those I'll give you at the end of the
semester.
The idea behind having so many slides is
that you can use this as a substitute to
reading the text.
LAL.
So we talk about quality attributes.
We have to understand quality attributes.
And quality attributes we talk about are
things like performance, usability,
security, modify, testability,
extensibility.
Security.
interoperability.
Availability is the type of attributes
that we'll be talking about, and this.
is a part about attributes.
I would like you to memorise.
That.
When we study attributes,
what do we actually study?
We study.
That there is.
An artefact.
Artefact could be the system.
It could be the network.
It could be memory, anything, anything,
any artefact.
This artefact has a stimulus and it
responds to the stimulus.
So something happens to it, it responds.
This stimulus has a source.
It could be human or it could be
non-human.
So, when the stimulus is there...
The response.
Needs to be measured.
So, you have a stimulus,
you have a response, you have a stimulus,
you have a response.
You should be able to measure the
response and you should know the source
of the stimulus.
So the source is a measurement and all
around the system is an environment.
So when we discuss any quality attribute,
and that's what this whole lecture is
about.
And I will not go into the details of the
individual thing, quality attributes,
but those of you who can go through the
slides even after the class,
and you want me to explain.
In detail.
You can,
all you have to do is call my attention
at the beginning of the...
next class. And of course,
during the class,
I'll be very happy to discuss.
This is what we try to understand. Now,
to be able to control inequality
attributes, these are some of them.
There is some management action.
that the architect may take recourse to
or recommend.
So this is a study of the quality
attribute.
And this is the action.
So,
the action is the various
responsibilities that relate to an
application or various aspects of the.
particular application.
You have to allocate the responsibilities,
allocate the responsibility to system
units, subunits,
or allocate the responsibility to per
people.
So that is something to be understood and
the architect may take decisions in that
regard.
Then you have a coordination model.
How do you coordinate all the activities
and resources that go into making of an
application?
Then we have the data model.
How do we structure the data?
How do we distribute the data?
How do we play around with the data?
How does the data interact with various
subsystems?
Management of resources.
What are the resources involved? Memory,
network, hardware.
Content distribution networks, manpower,
maintenance people, help desk, so...
How do you manage all these resources?
Then mapping among architectural elements,
the various elements in the architecture.
You may have a server,
you may have the client,
you may have various network layers.
How do you map?
responsibilities to them and how do they
remap the interaction between them.
Binding time decision.
What is a binding time decision?
Binding time decision is basically
objecting to the timing of any decision
that we might like to take.
Decision as to which resource will be
deployed.
deciding as to which resource will
interact with which resource.
Decisions as to.
How we will distribute the load?
And what do we mean by binding time,
binding time? Binding time,
certain decisions are taken in advance.
We call them early binding.
Some decisions are taken at the last
moment,
just about when the resources to be used.
You take a decision and use that resource.
It's called late binding.
You can obviously understand the meaning
and the benefits of each.
Early binding gives you a very clear idea
of what resources you are going to deploy
and how they are going to act out.
It becomes much easier to...
understand the resources much easier to
understand how they will interplay.
But it places limitations on the variety
in which these resources can be deployed.
Late binding,
sometimes called runtime binding.
Early binding is something called compile
time binding.
Late binding allows a dynamic utilisation
of resources as required.
Resources get used.
Then Architectures may take decisions
regarding choice of technology.
Whether to use cloud,
whether to use public cloud or private
cloud,
whether to use a dedicated data centre,
whether to have a server in office,
out of office,
cloud hosted or rack hosted or within the
office.
Which activity to be taken up with which
type of application?
If you thinking about database,
which database to take? SQL database,
no SQL database, object store.
These are the types of decisions
architects land up taking based on the
quality attribute requirements that
appear between them before them.
I normally tend to go very slow in the
beginning because I like people to get
the basic concepts clear.
If you have a basic concepts clear,
it's much easier to understand.
the rest of the lecture even without
sitting in the class.
So normally it's very important to have
that.
So,
let's start understanding quality
attributes.
We'll understand architecture requirement,
functionalities,
quality attribute consideration,
specifying quality attributes,
achieving quality attributes through
tactics.
This is going to be a very important
aspect of
Course.
Here,
I have got to make a comment from an
examination point of view.
I have found that, by and large,
there is a group of students.
To memorise the tactics that support.
A particular quality attribute.
That help you to achieve a particular
quality.
Now,
I don't know whether they memorise it or
they use some memory aid,
which they fission on the pocket or from
God knows where.
But they'll end up reproducing the slides
verbative, OK?
The point is,
the question does not ask you to list all
the tactics for a particular quality
attribute.
And when such students,
with so much of effort,
having repeated the names of all the
tactics that would have.
achieved a particular quality attribute,
get a zero, it is the answer,
they start wondering why that zero.
The reason you get a zero is if you're
working in a company and you could decide
that if a person has got a heart problem,
you go to the pharmacy,
ask the pharmacy for
the names of all the medicines that have
got to do with heart patient and give
them to the patient,
the patient is going to die.
Sure.
You've got to take a decision as to which
medicine, what dose,
and that's what the question paper is
normally about.
OK, so.
We expect you to read the question very
carefully. Normally,
these are case-oriented questions,
simplistic cases.
They are not the complicated cases you
find in a professional work environment.
So you take a look at the questions
properly.
Understand it, and then...
Simply give a pointed answer.
Even if you don't get marks for that,
you have the satisfaction of having used
your brains. OK.
How do we go around taking the decisions,
those management decisions we have talked
about later?
So we said that requirements can be
functional.
And efforts.
NFRs and quality attributes,
I will use this language interchangeably.
When I say NFRs,
I mean quality attributes.
When I say quality attributes,
I mean NFRs and constraints.
So constraints don't give you any freedom.
The customer wants it that way,
so you do it that way.
This is an architectural description
structure. Just take a look at it.
Understand for what is what functionality.
But.
Even when you wrote a college project,
you focused on functionality.
The relationship between functionality
and quality attributes is said to be
orthogonal. Orthogonal means...
Ninety degrees functional, non-functional.
They've actually got nothing to do with
one another.
For functional, you've got to know coding,
you've got to know the screen layouts,
you've got to know what input is to be
given, what output is to decide.
Non-functional.
Irrespective of what you're doing
functionally,
you're talking about availability,
performance, security, maintainability,
testability, usability, interoperability,
portability.
So these are NFRs, quality attributes.
So they are orthogonal to one another.
And in this course,
a concern is with NFRs.
We are not really bothered about
functions.
Though some functions may require
architectural
Involvement,
but that is taking care of the NFRs for
the same application.
Functional requirement is when the user
presses the green button,
the option dialogue should appear.
That's functional.
Then you see it.
Not testable.
Modifiable.
In.
Sometimes you wonder whether a quality
attribute has got to do with testability
or mean modifiability.
Is the system failure due to denial of
service attack or availability for home
and security usability?
Where should I put it?
So,
the denial of service system is not
available, performance become poor,
security is breached,
usability is impeded, so...
The point is, wherever you take it,
understand the use case.
So, you...
Depending on what your role in a company
is, you may look at it in your own way,
you may have your own vocabulary,
but the issue is that the problem has got
to be tackled.
So, you use quality attribute scenarios.
Without bothering,
where the quality attribute belongs.
And that was the first two cases,
very clearly a scenario.
And what is a scenario?
We said the scenario was source of
stimulus, acting on an artefact,
giving a response which is measurable,
and this entire thing happening in an
environment.
So this has got to be memorised.
Source of stimulus on an artefact
produces a response which has to be
measurable and which operates in an
environment.
Here, you can discuss each attribute,
concentrate on the underlying concern. So,
what is the fundamental concern over here,
irrespective of which attribute you put
it under? It's a.
So.
This has been listed,
same items listed again.
I've explained the meaning of each of
these.
If you want to understand more detail,
you can read through it.
You're free to stick to an older slide
and go through it if you think you need
to understand something better.
So.
A general quality attribute scenario is a
diagram of this kind.
You write down the name of the artefact,
you write down the stimulus,
you write down the response,
you write down the source,
and you write down the measurement and
state the environment. If you draw this,
we say that we have...
Provided a general quality attribute
scenario.
And this is what it looks like.
So, typical examples are given here.
So source, as I told you,
it could be human, non-human,
infrastructure, anything.
Stimulus can be a fault.
Can be a failure, can be an incoming.
response from another system.
It can be because of incorrect timing,
because of not getting an output.
The artefact could be a processor,
it could be a communication channel,
it could be the network,
it could be the storage,
it could be processors,
anything can be the artefact.
Response.
Any measurable attribute can be the
response,
and you should be able to measure it.
One thing very important that comes out
here is that...
You must be able to measure.
If you are talking about it as a quality
attribute,
our ability to measure is absolutely
important.
There are enough people who tell you no
quality.
You can feel it. How can you quantify it?
How can you say this is the quality?
Quality is nothing different. No,
that's not true. If you cannot state it,
you cannot collect your final cheque.
You got to.
Define.
The quality attribute.
in terms that can be measured,
which can be demonstrated to the customer,
and you can collect your payment.
K.
ANKUR stimulus.
In an artefact,
you have to take certain action.
And...
How do you?
Study.
What the artefact does to an input, so...
A fault takes place.
And the fault is reported to the
processor.
The processor is set right within 5
minutes.
So, the responses that...
The work that was required could not be
done.
The stimulus was that there was a fault.
Because some data was not there,
so you found out that is a fault.
The artefact is the processor which takes
immediate action. Now,
how the action is taken,
whether you have an automated mechanism
or you've got a infrastructure team that
takes the decision action,
somehow some action is taken.
And the response is that the fault is set
right within a certain period.
There's a measurement,
the response is sitting right,
the problem,
the stimulus was the problem itself,
and the artefact could have been,
storage could have been.
The process,
anything could be the artefact.
So on an artefact,
there's something happening which is
reacting.
There's a denial of service attack.
So, ANKUR,
if you could just remind me what type of
work you are doing.
Said I'm in the armed forces.
Oh, fantastic.
So what type of work do you do relating
to IT?
Sir,
I'm in a computation engineer and I'm
primarily looking after the radars and
communication.
Okay, Radha and communication.
So I know a little bit about
communication,
but I don't know about Radha.
So it's so nice to talk about an area
where you know nothing.
Can you tell me some problem that you
might face with a radar during, say,
war time?
Environment is voice on, OK?
The artefact is the radar.
You just tell me a problem that may
happen with the radar,
which you are capable of rectifying.
I said there are like multiple issues.
It can be related to the processing chain
or it can be related to a hardware
failure.
Okay.
No, I want you, no, no,
I want you to give one example as a case
study for everybody else to hear.
Just one example.
Say suddenly there's a communication
failure and for some reason the radar
simply stops.
Giving updates, you,
you can't see anything on the reduct.
Does it ever happen?
Yes, sir,
it does happen because from operator
Just goes.
workstation, when we give the command,
if there is the failure in the
Mmh.
communication channel,
then the command doesn't reach the
Mm.
antenna system and the electronic
magnetic waves don't get transmitted.
Like.
Okay, okay, now, okay,
now let's put it this way,
Or the beam formation doesn't take.
Please.
that that's exactly what has happened.
And on the telephone,
you got a call that the enemy aircrafts
have just left the station and they're
heading in the direction where you're
supposed to be tracking on the RATHODKAR.
What action will you take?
I'll just go like the modern generation
radars.
They have the built-in test equipment,
so we'll cheque what kind of the failure
Right.
it is. It is showing,
and if it is related to a particular LRU,
Right.
How long, how long,
a typical case that you faced in the
we'll replace that.
recent past,
how long did it take to rectify it?
So it depends on the type of failure if
it is a mechanical failure.
You know, I want to take the last case.
No,
I want you to take one case that actually
happened.
How long did it take you to rectify?
Don't have to tell me the detail of the
case. That probably confidential.
But just give me an indicative idea as to
how long it took you all to rectify it.
Any one case. We'll call it case X.
Sir,
maybe I would say it would be taking from
What?
half an hour time to maybe two to three
hours.
Super. So the responses, you rectified it.
based on certain test panels available to
you and test gadgets available to you and
certain test statistics available to you,
you're active immediately.
And the normal yardsticks, say,
with the army is that any such problem
should be rectified within half an hour.
Otherwise,
you should improve the quality of your.
systems. And depending on the criticality,
you may have different benchmarks.
So.
This type of system can be solved in half
an hour.
There may be other situations where
within 5 minutes you got to have it up
and going.
You may have alternate channels.
Or you may have backup equipment which
will take over.
Or you may have low powered equipment
which can handle part of the job without
So.
giving you that level of accuracy,
but it should come up within seconds.
Okay. So, so I've given you the stimulus.
Stimulus is what I.
SARAF.
Stimulus is a particular important
artefact stops functioning.
The architect we are talking about is a
RATHODKAR. The response is rectifying it.
Measurement is in how much time it should
be up and going.
Right, sir.
If you have hired, say, a company, say,
Bharat Electronics or somebody,
to solve this problem for you,
to set up the equipment for you.
You will give this bandit to that company.
Let's see,
this is a typical situation we face.
This is what can happen.
You give us a technical solution,
which we should never have a situation
where we are without an ability to track
enemy aircraft for more than 5 minutes.
Yes, sir.
So do we have a proper case study in
place?
You have a source of stimulus.
There might be some panel which let you
know,
or there may be some engineer who's on
duty who informs the stimulus is the
system is not functioning.
Artefact is a radar, responses,
rectifying it through automated processes
and manual processes.
And the measurement of responses,
certain types of problems should be
solved within 5 minutes.
Certain other categories can take half an
hour.
Certain other categories which are of a
minor nature can take 24 hours to rectify.
But all have to be stated and documented.
Correct.
Sir, OK.
because you will not make the payment to
BHARAT Electronics until they can satisfy
you that they've given you a solution
which meets these requirements.
Yes, sir. Understood. Thank you, sir.
So, this is,
so this is a general case of how you will.
present a quality attribute requirement
scenario.
And this is very important that you ask
this at this stage.
It helps people and you've helped me to
create a case study.
There's no better case study than the
case studies we create. In fact,
later on in this course,
We will take up the a case study in
avionics.
In fact, you know,
I will share with you some case studies
given by the author.
In the early editions of this book,
he used to cover the case studies in the
book itself, Lynn Bass. But later on,
he stopped the case studies from the book,
but he's made them available on his
website. And
I do believe I've got downloads of those,
so I'll share the downloads with you.
Maybe you can get them directly from his
site also.
Okay,
so the lovely case studies and most of
them are from an Air Force background
because the US Army spent a lot of money
setting up infrastructure for avionics,
that is for aircrafts,
for weapon delivery systems.
for ADC controls,
they've spent a lot of money on that.
And a lot of architecture has been
involved.
And even the author of a textbook,
he has been involved with this type of
activity professionally.
So his examples have got bearing there.
So the.
So you might find it interesting because
I'm sure you must be having a lot of
common,
a lot in common with the author of our
textbook.
Maybe you are a little younger because
he's been into it since ancient aircrafts
and you will be able to see it in the...
New light.
Okay.
No.
I had mentioned last time that we have...
For any management situation,
your strategies.
Good, Abhidaba.
I mean, may I ask you? In fact,
if you told me your background,
I might have forgotten.
So you just remind me.
If you just tell me a background,
I find it easier to give you examples.
Yeah, hi, sir. Am I audible?
I, yes, yes, very clear.
Yeah, I'm working in IT service company.
I'm in Cognizant. I have like, you know,
Oh, fantastic.
yeah, 14,
15 years of experience and working with
cloud software like Salesforce.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Okay, so let's look at it in perspective.
When you talked about it,
you said under severe load conditions,
right?
Quality attributes have to be separately
defined under different conditions.
And severe load conditions happens to be
an environment variable.
So your requirements under severe load
conditions will be different.
from those under normal load conditions.
And since you are working in an IT
environment,
you do accept that even when you do load
tests or performance evaluation,
you do it under various load levels.
And even your clients,
they give you specifications that under
this type of load conditions,
you should be able to achieve this type
of response.
Correct.
Yes, Sir.
So that's it. So,
and that is why it becomes so important
that when you specify a quality attribute
scenario,
you have to specify the environment.
And the type of load is part of the
environment variables,
which has to be specified. Okay.
Yeah.
Got it, sir.
So I think I think it answered your
question. OK.
Okay.
PRAJJWAL SHUKLA Okay.
OK, well put PRAJJWAL.
You stump me clean,
and you know I've been accused more than
once of being too jingoistic.
Some people say that, you know,
the vocabulary used is not fair,
but let's put it this way, PRAJJWAL.
The only rule in this course is to
enhance your vocabulary.
PRAJJWAL,
just give me one word which you find a
bit intimidating that we have used in the
last half an hour.
Just to get an example for me to
understand it a little better.
Hi, sir. Good morning. How have you been?
OK, so,
Yeah, yeah, hi.
so the last word which I found confusing
was artefact and stimulus.
As a product manager,
artefact is something which I consider as
Okay.
a documents or images,
but in terms of artefact,
Okay, okay.
when you called about systems and...
Other places into the vocabulary,
I just got confused. So,
Mm.
I'm a very young professional,
very early in my career,
a product manager professional,
and how do I go over to this course?
Yeah.
But...
Off.
No,
you must be a brilliant guy to become a
product manager in two years. Anyway,
that aside,
that's not what we are discussing now,
but I appreciate your mentioning of this
Yeah, fef.
thing.
So as far as architecture is concerned,
Mhm.
Anything that you decide.
happens to be important to you as a
stakeholder. Stakeholder is not a problem.
You're okay with the word stakeholder?
Yes, Sir, I am.
Yeah, so as a product manager,
definitely you are very concerned about
Yeah.
your stakeholders because so, yeah,
so let's say that you have your various
That is true, yeah.
Yeah.
stakeholders and as an architect.
Mhm.
You have a two-way relationship with your
stakeholders.
One is educating them because without
letting them know that you're trying to
educate them. Okay?
You face that situation.
Yeah.
Like you're explaining things to them,
but you're not sounding as if you're
explaining.
You make it sound as if you're trying to
understand.
Okay. Why are you explaining it to them?
Because you know that everything they
want, you cannot deliver.
At the same time.
Every stakeholder wants something
different.
You want to deliver one product,
and the product has got to achieve its
purpose.
And nobody seems to know what the purpose
is. That's the biggest issue.
So what you do is you struggle with these
Yeah.
people, explaining to them,
And you do it through scenarios.
So when the stakeholders tell you,
KHAN.
you know,
I want to make sure this happens, you say,
TOM.
okay,
I'll tell you how scenarios are made.
And I've got a scripter here who can
script a scenario.
You explain your scenario to me,
which you think is important.
So they tell you a story.
Understood.
And they say in the so and so environment,
so and so artefact,
and then you keep an open mind.
All the artefacts that you have listed is
Yeah.
an artefact.
Ohh.
We'll see later whether we'll attend to
that artefact or not,
but you keep it in mind.
Great.
So everything is an artefact.
Everything is in an environment.
So the moment a person tells you an
artefact, okay,
under what circumstances are you talking
about this problem?
So the person has to explain the
environment, the context, okay? That this,
maybe it's a document,
maybe it's just a diagram.
Yeah.
Ohh.
And people have a problem understanding
the diagram. That may be the stimulus.
Yeah.
Response maybe, you draw a new diagram.
Okay, so.
Who's having the problem?
Certain group of stakeholders don't
understand this very complicated
architecture diagrams you're presenting.
So they want you to write a little bit in
English. Okay,
I'll write a little bit in English.
No problem.
Mm.
Understood.
OK, no.
When we talk about stimulus,
it is what is making,
what are we concerned about,
what is happening to the system because
of which?
We have to respond.
If you don't need to respond,
that's not a situation at all we are
bothered about.
But if we need to respond,
how quickly we need to respond,
or with what magnitude we need to respond,
or what do we need to achieve?
I.
No.
That is the measurement of the response.
And as an architect,
you've got to deliver measurable
parameters,
otherwise you'll never get your payment.
because you've got to commit quality
attributes and quantity attributes are
very funny.
People assume that everybody knows,
nobody knows.
In the beginning of the thing,
people will tell you, oh,
No.
the system should be user-friendly.
And at the end, when you do it, they say,
Mm.
this is the most un-user-friendly system
I've ever seen in my life. Now,
what happens to your payment?
E.
Right, so you...
Understood.
So, you have to quantify, yeah,
so let's look at Aditian.
Is it?
And you give us an example of a word
which you found a little intimidating.
Maybe now you understood it,
but still mentioned something.
So one more question I have for you.
As I told you that I'm very early in my
Yeah, yeah.
career and I have not done my engineering
very well since I passed out in 2022 and
The.
two years and by in COVID.
So how do I prepare myself to understand
Okay.
all of these?
topics better. I mean,
I understand the system architecture,
what it is and how it goes about,
but how do I understand the course really
I, okay, I don't know. Yeah,
I don't know whether a course like this I
well? So is there a prerequisite?
should be dishing out the old man advice,
but being fairly old,
Yeah.
I have to come out with advice which is
old.
Okay.
What my normal recommendation to
everybody is prioritise.
M.
What do you have to do in life?
If you haven't eaten for the last two
days, forget about the course,
Okay.
find out something to eat and eat it. Yep,
yes, yes. Who am I speaking to?
Hello.
Ah, hello, sir. Ah, Adiyanti.
Yeah, but yeah, Aditi. OK,
I'll get back to PRAJJWAL. Aditi,
Thanks.
just give me one word which you consider
jinguistic.
Actually,
so actually I couldn't understand the
One word.
artefacts words still,
because I'm not a product manager,
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I'm just a software engineer, so...
Yeah.
Okay.
Don't insult so many people in one group.
Almost everybody in this class is a
software engineer.
KHAN.
Don't say just a software engineer.
You're a very proud software engineer.
Who am I? Okay.
So I spent my whole life just doing
Yeah, so.
software engineering.
So we are not just software engineers.
We are great people.
Okay, anyway, get back to artefact.
I'll get back to artefact. Okay,
Yeah, so...
I see.
so continuing with the how to prioritise.
So what really happens is...
My recipe for this course is that.
Don't give it more time than you can
afford to give it,
taking all other priorities into account.
But definitely give it a finite amount of
time,
even if it is 5 minutes a day or it is
one hour per week.
Once you decide to give it time,
Hey.
just go through the slides.
and mark out the words you don't
understand.
Okay.
Then, then just Google them.
And give highest priority to
understanding the vocabulary.
This course is going to give you one hell
of a lot of technical vocabulary.
Hell of a lot of it.
And all I want you to know is the meaning
of the words. Nothing beyond that.
Don't try to go deep. In this course,
depth is not required.
But not understanding the meaning of a
word may work out very expensive.
Is that all right?
Yes, sir.
PRAJJWAL, that was for you, OK?
Yes, sir. OK.
Okay.
No, I get to Adiente.
Oh.
Yes, sir.
Identity.
Yes, Sir.
Artefact.
You've got various things in front of you.
You've got a laptop.
You got slides?
Yes, sir.
Yes.
Oh.
You're a software engineer,
you must have seen some UML diagrams in
your lifetime.
Yes.
class diagrams, sequence diagrams,
state diagrams.
Mhm, mhm.
You must have seen force code,
you must have seen object code,
Yes.
you must have seen dependencies.
Yes.
You must have heard about storage units.
You may not have seen it,
but you do believe that there is a
storage unit in your laptop.
You do believe that there are storage
units available in the cloud.
Mhm.
Oh.
You do believe that you are accessing
this class over a network?
Yes.
I don't know whether you're on a VPN or
you are on a public IP or a static IP.
All these things that we are mentioning
and any number of things that you and I
Move.
are capable of discussing,
which can be mentioned as nouns, nouns,
Mm.
noun, NOU noun.
All these are nouns, isn't it?
No, yes.
Everything is an artefact.
Okay.
Okay,
now an artefact has to exist in an
Okay.
E.
environment. It doesn't exist in a vacuum.
The the the environment of a hard disc,
maybe that you've got extensive
Mhm.
read-write, you save,
you got a security application where
video recording is going on.
You require a very robust hard disc for
that purpose.
Hmm.
Okay,
so you have to specify the environment in
which that artefact exists.
Then what are the type of issues that can
arise relating to the artefact and how
quickly you need a resolution?
The response is always a resolution.
Some action has to be taken.
Sometimes the action may be to just to
put that device out of service so that
people are not hassled.
You simply declare on the site,
the site is not functional.
The will inform you as soon as it is
working.
That could be like an extreme case
scenario.
Yes.
But how long will it not work?
How long not working is acceptable?
You may have a service level agreement,
SLA,
Ohh.
which says that if you're down for more
than five days in a year,
Well...
you'll have to start paying penalty.
No.
OK, so these are measures.
Yes, well.
And,
and the responses that you get it back on
M.
time.
So this is as far as lingua is concerned,
but yes,
this is not the only language that's
going to give you trouble.
You move a little further into this class
and you'll have to have tactics.
And tactics can be so jinguistic,
you will feel lost.
Don't bother about the exam or the marks
you will get in the exam and what you
have to memorise. But I can tell you.
that if you do not know the meaning of
each of the tactics that are being
explained in today's and next class.
Mm.
you will find yourself deficient in an IT
environment. Okay,
Okay.
so exams set aside the language which we
will find.
Mhm.
which defines tactics which are used to
achieve these quality attributes.
You have no choice but to understand that
language,
whether it gets you good marks or does
not get you good marks,
whether you are a good student or a bad
student, irrespective.
You are all doing respectable jobs.
in the IT industry and you have to,
your power of communication or your power
of addressing work is totally dependent
on your vocabulary.
Mm.
Vocabulary is what makes us communicate
with one another. Tell me one thing,
Adyanti, you've heard of Pythagoras?
Pythagoras?
Yes.
Yes, yes.
What do you think of when I say
Pythagoras?
X ^2 + y ^2 is equal to Z squared if the
X&
Yes, excellent.
Y are at right angles to one another. See,
just because we share a vocabulary.
Yes.
Okay,
you and I have gone through common
education. Pythagoras means so much to us.
You're already saying right-angled
Yes.
triangles. You're already seeing 3, 4, 5.
Ohh.
On 96 all these type of combinations.
That is because we possess a common
vocabulary. Similarly,
if you're going to survive in the IT
industry and you're going to communicate
Ohh.
with stalwarts of the industry and grow
in life,
Ohh.
The basic requirement is forget
understanding details of technology.
You must possess a vocabulary, okay?
And if you're getting this opportunity at
Yeah.
a young age.
You thank your stars.
And for people who are more advanced,
So.
as you've seen,
we have got so many people who are 20,
25 years experience doing this course.
For them,
Yes, sir.
it is a revisitation and perfection of
vocabulary. See,
because after so many years of working,
I'm still coming across new words.
And then new words being created,
new models getting created.
What?
You know, and most of us,
the half-life of knowledge on what we do
Mm.
is not more than five years.
I don't know whether you ever heard this
language, half-life of knowledge.
Have you heard about it?
No, sir.
It says.
That.
What you learned five years back,
up to five years back,
only half of it is useful today.
The rest of it has come in the last five
years.
OK,
which means whatever knowledge you gather.
Okay.
Mhm.
Half of it becomes useless in five years.
You have to learn something new.
So in such a fast-tracked environment,
you've got to keep track of what's going
on. And this course,
the main thing achieved is you come to
Mm.
know what is going on.
Yeah.
So right up to,
so that's why right up to the end of the
Mm-hmm.
course, we'll be touching so many things.
You're not supposed to start getting
intimidated.
You should not feel that you could not go
deep into it. We don't even want depth.
But yes, the essence of it,
you must understand. Okay.
Thanks.
So, just, yeah, just more, yep, yep.
Um...
Hello, sir.
Sir, this is Sirisha.
I understand the importance of
Yes, yes, we should.
terminology and jargons.
May I share my understanding in the chat?
Yeah.
Is that okay?
E.
Okay, normally not okay,
but if you are happier doing it there,
I'll quickly look at the chat. Okay,
have you put something already in the
chat? I'm not going to wait.
But.
I put something, Newton's third law,
for all action,
That's all.
there's an equal and opposite reaction.
If the reaction creates a negative impact,
then action is a stimulus reaction,
the response, situations, environment.
Where was this?
Oh, is it an artefact? OK, this is you.
Thanks for making the class sound better.
Any correlation you bring up to be able
to understand is very useful. So,
whether the reaction is negative and
positive part of it,
I would like to leave out,
because a reaction is a reaction.
Okay,
I wouldn't look at a reaction as negative
or positive,
but we are not looking for reaction, okay,
in this case, we are looking for response.
So reaction is something that, see,
because we are looking at systems
engineers.
The reaction is something the system does
autonomously;
a response is something that we put in
effort to achieve, OK?
So I will distinguish between the word
reaction and response.
Would that be acceptable to you?
Okay, sir.
Yes, thank you.
Yeah,
but it was nice that you put something
like this there. See,
you notice that I've spent a lot of time
just understanding the general tactics,
okay?
Because we simply won't have time in
class to go through the scenario.
for individual quality attributes. Still,
I will try to track some of them,
which I consider are important.
I'll explain to them, to you.
And in the next class,
you will have an opportunity to take up
things with me.
Okay, what is a tactic?
I just told you a little while back that
you have...
Strategy, tactics, operations.
So, when we...
Talk about strategy, it is the overall.
Long-term.
objective that we have sent out,
like how we are going to achieve the long
term objective.
It is something that the senior
management fixes up.
The architect decides that, okay,
this is what I want to achieve.
Tactics are like, you know,
recently we had
A lot of soccer,
lots of people even in India stayed away
to watch FIFA.
Every team has a strategy when they
encounter another team.
So.
Spain meeting Argentina.
Argentina had the strategy.
And Spain had their strategy.
Then within that strategy,
when the game is on,
they deploy certain tactics,
the pass and play time wastage tactics.
keeping position tactics.
These are tactics. Similarly,
we as architect having decided the
overall strategy,
we deploy tactics to fine tune quality
attributes to a specific requirement.
And operations are making sure that the
tactics work.
The players go out there,
we know what tactic we are going to
deploy,
so you go and play the best football you
can, and if the better team wins, so...
Design patterns,
we'll be talking about architectural
patterns here after the midterm exam.
They are complex. They are strategic.
And once you decide to follow a pattern,
you still may not be able to achieve the
quality attributes the exact way you want
to.
So what you do is you deploy tactics and
we'll be seeing a lot of tactics in this
course.
So.
We talked about understanding this,
and this part which talks about managing
architect, this itself.
My young friends may consider it very,
very chinguistic, as you said.
No.
Jargon.
Now,
jargon sometimes becomes a very unfair
word for good professional vocabulary,
but we use it without meaning any evil.
So more often than not,
jargon is a complex words used just to
impress here.
It is not a question of just impressing.
We do not communicate as architects
unless we have this vocabulary.
So I've mentioned this earlier,
allocation responsibility,
coordination model, data model,
management of resources,
mapping among architectural elements,
binding time decisions,
choice of technology. These are the.
type of decisions.
So let's talk about each one of them.
So I would pick up just now.
These things in general,
and then we'll alley all of these to
individual quality attributes, so...
Allocation of responsibility,
what does it mean?
Identifying the important
responsibilities,
including basic system functions.
What is the system supposed to achieve
even functionalities?
the architecture infrastructure.
What is an architectural infrastructure?
What network? What storage?
What processing power?
what type of storage, whether it's RAM,
ROM.
Storage, distributed storage,
object storage, database storage,
all that is is infrastructure and
satisfaction of quality attributes.
You want to satisfy the quality
attributes.
Who be responsible?
And what would be these quality
attributes we would like to achieve?
Whether these determine these
responsibilities,
whether they'll be allocated.
On runtime or long runtime?
Non-runtime is in advance.
You will decide in advance that this is a
person who will be handling the radar.
On runtime is.
You're running it, you have a problem,
then you get, say...
There's a terrorist attack,
you ask for the Rapid Action Force to
come.
These are decisions which the Rapid
Action Force or the special security
forces are not available all the time.
When a situation develops,
you have a mechanism to transport them to
the problem location as soon as possible.
So these are decisions taken at runtime.
So,
you have to decide that certain types of
problems,
whether you will be solving them when the
problem occurs, or will you be having pre?
predetermined solutions which will be
taken at the time of designing the system
itself. We call them non-runtime.
And decisions which are taken when the
systems are running are called runtime
decisions.
So this responsibility allocation is
something
The architect will decide on coordination
model.
Identify the elements of the system that
must coordinate or are prohibited from
coordinating. So these are the...
elements which will be allowed to
coordinate with one another.
These elements,
there will be no coordination.
They will only be utilised the way they
are.
The properties of the coordination such
as timeliness, concurrency, completeness,
correctness, consistency.
When you coordinate or you interact
between two elements,
What should be the timing?
How often should they communicate?
For example,
your mobile should communicate with the
GPS system every 5 seconds,
every one second, or every 5 minutes.
It will depend on the application.
If your application requires a very rapid
update of location,
it will be again and again.
If your application is just to give your
location to your friends,
so you want to pin your location and
update it on the Google servers or your
WhatsApp servers or whatever it is.
Periodically,
every 5 minutes may be good enough, so...
These type of decisions have to be taken
as to with what currency,
whether it's got to be online or it can
be every night update.
How complete,
complete means to what details should the
information be shared?
What is the importance of correctness of
information then?
How much of consistency is consistency
means every time you've got to give the
information of the same detail so that
people know what to expect.
Choose the communication mechanism.
How do I communicate?
Whether I pick up the data from a server,
I store the data locally.
So these type of decisions need to be
taken.
So, whether...
Two systems will work asynchronously or
synchronously.
Talking word jargon.
Oh.
But.
P.
Oh.
Pratush.
You said, may not be aware of IRCTC.
Oh God, we've lived with IRCTC.
What about it, Pratyush?
What would you like to say about IRCTC?
You're working on that?
You're a part of the ICTC team.
No, sir, it was Abhinav stated an example,
and I thought that you may not be aware
Okay, okay. No, no, no, no, no.
I don't live in Canada. I just, at my age,
of this.
you know,
I can afford to work from anywhere.
I still do development work,
but I just keep travelling.
I've got my family distributed all over
the world. I belong to Kolkata,
by the way. Last six months,
I've been in Canada,
Okay.
but I intend to go back
In the next two weeks, so that's it.
So, a good example over the years,
most people curse it, but still hundreds,
millions of transactions. Yeah,
who mentioned this? Oh, Abhinav. So,
Abhinav, about IRCTC,
I have seen the Indian Railways
reservation, how it's totally with IRCTC.
right from the day it started. In fact,
there's a very close relationship.
The original system for railway
reservation was written in a language
called. Abhinav, would you have any idea?
Uh, no, no sir.
Portre info.
Shocking, isn't it?
It was in Fortran 4 and it was the vendor
Oh.
who had a major role in this was a
company called ORG Systems.
You don't even know that the company
exists today.
ORG Systems.
It was one of the major software
developers in the country at one time.
There were three.
Very big.
What do you call it?
Indian computer companies.
One of them was ORG systems.
One of them was DCM data products.
It was very big on DCM data products.
They also almost vanished.
I'm told they've got a software company
which does some work and you had a
company called HCL.
HCL came up a little later,
but it has had the longest survival.
Now the ORG system.
In the early days,
BITS Pilani started a M Tech computer
science programme.
First pass on batch was either 19,
I think 1979. Okay, yeah, 1979.
And the entire batch was handed
appointment letters by URG systems
without even interviews.
Okay,
and you had lots of people from BITS
working for RAJ and this completed the
system. It's an example of a very,
very robust system.
There have been problems,
mostly of performance, the load handling.
But the type of load and the type of
accuracy they've handled overall,
considering the loads they've handled,
it is something that I have admired all
along.
I have lived with all the problems.
I have faced their problems.
It was used to be almost impossible
buying tickets from Kolkata during Durga
Pooja time,
because everybody in Kolkata either
wanted to come to Kolkata or they wanted
to go out of Kolkata. So put together.
Getting any.
Booking in Kolkata was very difficult. OK,
let's take a 10 minutes break. OK,
we've covered only 19 slides,
but we've covered uncovered a lot.
Let's take a 10 minutes break. All right.
So, brick.
OK, welcome back.
So this was the coordination model.
Then we talk about the data modelling.
What are the data abstractions?
Any data structures that are there?
Any storage of data?
how the data items, how they created,
how they initialise accessed.
how they are stored for persistent
storage, any manipulation,
any translation.
Any.
And eventually, how data is destroyed?
Then.
The concept of metadata.
So, what beta data is required?
also needs to be decided because metadata
is data about data.
In the case of a database.
The data board data contains the
structure of the files,
the type of variables, the type of fields,
whether they are characters,
object stores, binary, strings,
whatever it is.
So this type of information.
also has got to be decided how the data
is to be organised.
Whether you'll keep them.
In.
remote storage,
local storage in an RDBMS in a NoSQL
database.
how many copies, what type of replication,
whatever backup,
what type of distribution,
all these things regarding data need to
be decided.
Management of resources.
What are the resources?
What are the determine the limits of each
resource?
Like how much resource would you provide?
Whether you will provide...
load balancers,
whether you'll provide multiple servers
or you'll increase the RAM.
or you have surveillance,
these type of decisions on resources may
have to be taken.
What are the system limits that will
manage the resources?
Manage the resources may be managed by
load balancers,
they may be managed by content delivery
networks, they may be managed through.
service registries.
So service locators,
these type of decisions need to be taken
by the architect. Now, again,
you may have found that the language I've
used here may be a bit difficult.
I will.
If you want me to explain the beginning
of next class,
you can ask me if your search on Google
does not give you an adequate explanation.
Then how resources are going to be shared,
how they're going to be allocated,
how they're going to be made available.
And what will be the impact of shared
resources, dedicated resources,
what extent resources will be provided?
These type of decisions will have to be
taken. Mapping among architectural limits.
You have modules.
One was module structures.
You divided your system into modules.
Another approach was component and
connectors. You had components,
they were connected. Now,
how these elements relate to one another?
There may be a usage and relationship.
There may be a relationship of a class,
subclass.
You might certain processes may be done
by certain elements.
Where will the calculation be done?
Where will the business logic reside?
What amount of computation will be done
in the database itself?
So.
what items will be assigned to the data
model.
You might decide that certain type of
activity should be handled in the data
model itself.
Mapping.
Off.
static modules with runtime modules like
you have your classes.
objects whether it should have
multi-threading or not.
How?
How WILP?
you instantiate objects.
Where will you instantiate?
How will you share data?
Whether you'll be using JSON or you'll be
using a database store.
There could be various ways of
transporting data from one point to
another. How will you transport data?
How will you make data available across
the network?
These are decisions that will need to be
taken by any time.
Allocation of responsible.
whether it is build time or runtime.
Build time is when you are designing the
system,
you may bind the responsibilities between
2 modules.
Or runtime means dynamically while the
system is running,
it finds out available resources and
utilises them.
A typical situation would be.
Say, you got a.
server and you put a client.
The.
Build time decision could be that this
will be bound to a particular server and
the server will respond to the queries of
this particular client.
A dynamic model would be that as and when
information is required,
it goes to a service discovery network,
finds out where this information could be
available or where this computation can
be done.
Whatever resources are available,
it connects with them and gets the
information or gets the computation done.
So this would be a runtime binding.
And...
Then we come to a choice of technology.
You have various technologies available,
various classes of database,
various types of RDBMS,
various classes of say financial systems.
So.
Which ones do you use?
You may have a number of APIs available
to support the same tasks at different
costs,
which would be adequate for your purpose.
Then.
What type of...
Knowledge would you require with your
support teams?
What type of support teams are required?
What should be the technical knowledge?
And then finding out what would be the
side effects,
whether you can depend on a particular
type of technology,
whether this technology is likely to
survive or not.
Sometimes you take a decision to go in
for a new technology,
which has a lot of promise.
And then the technology goes out of
market.
And you simply left.
with a lot of resources invested,
depending on the technology and the
technology ceases to exist.
This is one reason very many,
very often people like to go with a
technology which is in abundant usage.
so that you don't die alone.
If there are enough people who are
depending on the technology,
there'll be some way to keep the
technology alive.
So these are the type of decisions you
may like to take.
So, this is in summary.
availability. Now, at this stage,
I'm just not going to cover the quality
attributes one by one.
But I'm going to mention.
One or two, which pose a lot of problems,
so...
I've got availability,
I've got performance.
I got interoperability.
I've got...
extensibility.
I've got maintainability.
Testability.
Usability.
Security.
Okay.
Yeah, sure, you know what?
Okay, the last thing, it's okay.
Shara Larry Coval.
SAURAV, you had any exposure to Kubal?
Hello, sir. Actually,
I work work on mainframe support, so yeah,
Yeah.
I have like around 10 years I have worked
on Pobola and JCL and both things.
Yeah.
Okay, okay. Lovely language, yeah.
I have done some early work in Kobol.
really puts your concepts very clear.
You start understanding data structures
very well.
Of course.
Yes, I mean, and as I worked on support,
so mostly I'm relating most of these
things with the support aspect of it,
like SLA,
Okay.
and then you have this application of
responsibility,
Look, yeah.
so it's like L1 and L2 and L3 for on run
time, so I am doing it like that.
Yeah.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, great.
So if I was, is there any of these?
See, these are just taken a handful of.
Quality attributes,
but this the author of a book has
considered this important,
and in this course,
we will be covering these quality
attributes,
and your notes will have enough
information about this,
but if out of these,
I ask you to suggest one or two which.
can be a little confusing to people.
Even before explaining to others,
I would like to explain those.
Which one would you choose?
And since you've been so many years in
support.
Which do you think would be a little
confusing to the people who are new to
the language?
If I take the example of like mainframe,
so it's maintainability and extensibility
because they are like,
we don't have much resources left for
OK.
maintaining mainframe systems.
So that's why it's like that.
Luke.
Okay, okay,
I will explain the meaning of these two
and I'll explain even interoperability.
See,
because the others know availability is
so many people. We all understand,
like you said,
you understand SLA and most of the SLAs
have got to do with availability.
If your system is down, you get penalised.
Performance,
almost every system goes through thorough
performance tests, load tests,
stress test, test test, test test,
everything to do with performance.
You've got people who are designated as
performance engineers and you have to
make sure it's fine.
But these extensibility.
The interoperability, maintainability,
extensibility,
also people more or less understand that
it's an ability of a system to extend its
capability.
But interoperability and maintainability
are two terms where lots of youngsters
have confusion.
So let me take maintainability first,
because maintainability is something I've
seen appearing in so many question papers
and examinations,
and people tend to misunderstand what
maintainability means.
Uh, you know...
When people talk about maintainability,
they talk about the...
Resources available to maintain a system.
But maintainability is not the resources
available to maintain a system.
Maintainability of a system is the ease
of which a system can be maintained.
So when you invest in maintainability,
it means that you design your system in
such a way.
that if any maintenance is required,
it can be done with a minimal use of
resources.
Sure of ever been able to correctly put
it across.
Uh, yes, sir.
And this is often a source of confusion.
So what happens is maintainable systems
Okay.
tend to become very expensive.
That is why.
If you don't spend on maintainability,
you spend a lot on maintenance.
Now, if a system is for what time use,
will you spend on maintainability?
If it's one time, use nose.
Yeah, no,
so we might as well save the cost.
Don't put an effort into making it
maintainable.
But if the system that you see...
being in use for the next 10 years,
15 years, 20 years.
And any system will require maintenance
because the specifications will change,
the requirements will change.
The environment will change.
The technologies available will change.
So change is something which is the only
thing that is permanent in a system.
You should continue requiring change.
So if you think change is going to be
required and is going to be a system
which needs to be up all the time,
then it becomes worth investing in
maintainability.
How do you make a system maintainable?
We will look at the tactics for
maintainability.
So one of our notes here will be on
maintainability and we'll be discussing
tactics for maintainability and how we
manage maintainability.
So, very good. Thank you very much.
Next is interoperability.
In today's world.
A lot of effort is going on.
And certain environments have made
interoperability a part of the design.
An area where I've had some exposure to
and I have reason to know about is
Android.
In Android,
there's so many applications running.
And they simply use other applications as
if they are part of the same application.
Like if you have a camera application,
you are using the native camera provided
by the window.
And applications interact with each other
so seamlessly. So the Android environment,
the whole structure is such that
applications can interoperate. Today,
you've got a fantastic,
I know there are people in this class
also who are working on SAP last time.
Somebody mentioned that among his
responsibilities are working on SAP.
So.
SAP is.
Software,
which can handle various aspects of
business, including financial, marketing.
Operations.
It can connect up,
it is interoperable with a large variety
of database.
You can get the database from them,
or you can take any third party database,
it will interoperate.
And that is what makes.
a software like that so successfully
because it has got interoperability.
I'm, hello, hi, yep, yeah,
so I'm working on SFP space, I know, yeah.
Uhh.
Yeah, yeah, you're welcome.
Okay, yeah,
so tell us something about
interoperability as far as SIP is
concerned. It's a good,
you can set a good example for people.
Oh yeah.
So, SAP,
we came across that I work for the
aviation industry where we have a
different databases and we are using a
The.
third party application with that
database to get the different statistics
and analysis for the aviation industry,
how we are scheduling flights and that
all.
Okay.
And what database are you using?
So, there are...
So, earlier it used to be a SQL database.
We have a physical server. Nowadays, yeah,
MS, MS, MS, Microsoft is good, MS is good.
now.
Yeah, MS SQL. Yeah,
nowadays it we it is nowadays we have a
OK, right.
AWS our Amazon different cloud spaces we
have we have a different tenants and
Right.
there we have in that cloud we have a two
types of different clouds.
Right.
One is public cloud,
another is private cloud.
So, publicly allowed to share.
Mm.
And what are DBMS?
What are DBMS are you using there on the
cloud?
Public cloud, public cloud,
they have they have their own cloud cloud
spaces, cloud servers, so yeah,
so but there are different tenants like
Right, right.
Amazon, AWS, they and Google,
they provide the this cloud space and
M.
based on based on the requirement type.
Okay.
How much computing space we required,
so they will provide the services and it
Mm.
is as pay as services, so SARAF services,
so we consume the services and using in
that in that model.
Okay, okay.
And are you using any RDBMS from AWS?
Yeah, so there, there,
they have a monitoring monitoring tools
and they have dashboards, so, so, yeah,
so based on the based on the volume or
Right.
Okay.
the based on the data,
so that they will be charge accordingly,
Okay, okay.
yes.
But your application you use continues to
be SAP.
Application application part is SAP,
but in some of the scenarios we also use
Okay.
integrate with a third party application
for like, for example,
Okay.
in I give you example for like fleet
management,
we have this shell shell card system card
management,
Okay, okay.
so from there we there we capture the
records and then we do invoicing.
Yeah.
How much consumption has been done for
the?
Right. Yeah, in fact,
that's a very popular approach taken by a
number of companies,
particularly in India,
because the licencing cost of SAP is per
terminal becomes quite expensive.
And in your fleet system,
you want to have a large number of users.
So,
and SAP is good interoperability with any
other system, Andy.
You have third party system set up with
large number of connexions,
and you interoperate with SAP data inward
and outward,
and whereby you have a specialised
software number one,
because the third party has developed it
exclusively for fleet management,
whereas SAP may not.
Suit your requirements exactly,
plus it gives you a huge economy on the
per terminal cost. At least,
when I last encountered a situation like
this with SAP,
I found that it was making a major
difference in the...
A thing for the client.
Yes.
Yeah, I hear you.
I don't know whether, yeah.
I give you one scenario, for example,
I had implemented for this IOCL,
so there are terminals,
there are terminals that some of the
Okay.
outlets, what they do, so,
so they have a they have a lesser volume,
M.
but the same from the same they show they.
Mm.
That is higher side, so in that case,
that yeah, so in that case,
Right.
that that there will be a possibility
that they might be have done at
alteration, right? So then we have it,
then we have proposed a solution,
Okay.
so all the all the all the outlets or the
terminals,
the sales will be counted as online.
Mm.
So, we will cheque that,
we will cheque the we do the
OMKAR.
reconciliation,
what will be the in volume and out volume,
Okay.
so we will come to know,
we will come to know what is the what is
Okay, okay. Right.
the what is the differences and how,
so we will be able to gather that problem.
M.
Mm.
Okay,
we've been speaking to BHANU GURURAJ,
Yeah, BHANU them, yes, yes, yes.
right? Right. Welcome, welcome, welcome.
Thank you.
We've got some more information here.
technology interoperately becomes easy.
API and headless, KAUSIK, yeah.
Kaushik technology interoperately becomes
easy.
Yes, sir. So, I mean,
while we are discussing, like, you know,
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, K.
traditionally, I mean,
making interoperability, sorry,
interoperability become, I mean,
earlier it was quite, you know, difficult,
Yeah.
Right.
right? So, you know,
building system which can communicate to
Right.
each other.
But as we advance in technology with API
and API based headless technology,
Late.
Lent.
so nowadays, you know,
connecting systems or connecting,
Right, right.
you know,
applications become a little bit easy,
right? So,
and that's probably a better advantage
with the technology nowadays.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Compared to, if I look at, you know,
even 10 or 15 years back, right? So...
True, true, true. Nowadays,
more secure networks,
definitely standardised APIs,
it has not really become easier.
Right.
One of the reason things have become
easier is you don't have a choice today.
If your system...
isn't sufficiently interoperable,
you can't survive in the market.
Correct.
People will not be interested in you.
So you at least you've got the concept
Absolutely.
absolutely right.
So I just want to mention these two.
Sears.
Now let us go systematically whatever we
can cover in the next.
20 minutes we'll try to cover.
So we are taking availability now as a
first example and when we talk about
availability.
Let us understand what we be.
Mean by availability,
this a typical example.
Availability means say.
I am supposed to be available for this
class.
If the people come to this class and half
the time they come,
they find I'm not there, well,
my availability is poor.
If you access some information from the
server and the server doesn't provide you
the information.
That's an availability issue.
So...
Availability is.
The resource which is meant for a
particular purpose should continue,
should be.
Provided when it is required,
in the event that there's any problem,
the recovery or the repair should be
within the.
Timeline specified in my scenario.
So,
which means you basically taking care of
outage. Now,
this is the availability general scenario,
the same scenario where we talk about
source, stimulus, artefact, environment,
response, and response measurement.
In the case of
Availability.
We've had,
we've been talking about artefact.
It could be the system processor,
it could be the communication channel,
it could be the storage,
could be the processors, any of them.
At the environment, it could be normal,
startup, shutdown, repair port,
degraded service, overload operation.
I think we discussed sometime back that
the environment is important.
So considering all this.
What would be the stimulus that
availability is suffering? A fault,
omission, crash, incorrect timing,
incorrect response? Any of these happens,
you have to take action.
Action is the response.
Detect the fault, log the fault,
or notify appropriate people.
Recover from the fault,
disable the source, just mask the fault.
Make the system temporarily unavailable,
just that component.
Sometimes you find the bank.
This service is not currently available.
Please try after some time.
You can mask the fault for the time being,
and...
so that it doesn't cause any damage.
Or you operate in a degraded mode.
Sometimes you find that certain important
sites, they stop giving you reports.
They say, please log your request.
The report will be sent by e-mail.
That could be a degraded service.
Instead of giving you an online response,
it just logs your request.
Now, how do you measure it?
What percentage of the time it's
available?
How much time is taking to detect a fault?
How long does it take to repair a fault?
This could be specifications of
availability prescribed by the
stakeholders, so this is typically.
And you don't write all the conditions,
any one of the stories.
may be important to a particular customer.
So the customer will give a story with
this broad guideline indicating what type
of availability they require under what
situation.
They will give the story under different
situations also. Under normal operations,
start up, shut down, repair mode,
degraded, overload.
For each one,
a different story may be given,
but this is how stories are given.
So, sample scenario, heartbeat monitor.
artefact determines the server is
non-responsive.
The server is non-responsive,
this is the source of stimulus.
Source Heartbeat Bolt.
This is the artefact.
Non-responsive is the stimulus;
the system informs the operator.
This is response.
and continues to operation with no
downtime measure.
Downtime, no downtime.
Responses inform the operator. Artefact.
So here is exactly how we fit in the
scenario.
So, goal of the tactics would be.
A failure occurs,
the system no longer delivers a service
consistently with specifications.
A fault or combination of faults has the
potential to cause a failure.
You've got to make sure that the fault
does not convert into failure.
Availability tactics enables the system
to ensure faults so the service remain
compliant with the specification.
So you should be able to endure the fault.
The tactics keep fault from becoming
failure.
Or at least bound the effect of the fault
and make possible repairs. So this is the.
Response that is expected, so fault.
For mass energy payment, this is the...
And this is the diagram which I was
talking about.
Memorising it is not an answer.
And this is what I exactly mean when I
say that.
You should be, you should know the jargon.
So under availability tactics,
detect fault, recover from fault,
prevent fault.
These are the various actions can be
taken. And for each of these action,
from recover to fault,
preparation and repair, or reintroduction.
Now, these are various tactics.
They've been explained in these slides
and you can read them about them in
Google if you don't understand.
If you still don't understand in the
beginning of next class,
please bring it up to me.
I will explain it.
But this is what I mean by building a
vocabulary.
And building this vocabulary,
as I repeated in the beginning of the
class, it is not a question of...
Ohh,
examination is a question of knowledge,
so...
Oh.
Anupam SARKAR,
do I need to answer that or have you
understood now?
So I think I understood,
so basically it's a system where the ship
fault is occurring. Is that the source?
No, no, no, no, that's the artefact.
The source is the system that informs you
that the fault is occurring.
Okay, thank you.
or all the system that requires you to
take action.
Okay.
Yeah, okay.
OK, that's the source,
and the system itself is the artefact.
And see,
all these systems will help you to.
Achieve.
availability.
And how each one will do it is something
that you must be aware of.
And given a small scenario,
you should be able to choose which one
will be appropriate.
And even if you give a wrong answer,
giving a proper explanation will at least
get you somewhere.
Though most of the time when the paper
sets a question,
they have one or at best two of these
things in mind as the solution.
And they'll normally prepare a question
paper leading to a particular course of
action.
So reading the question paper very
carefully becomes very important.
OK,
and the next few slides explains these,
see all these I.
In India.
All of them are explained to me.
So,
and now we come to checklist for
availability.
Those same management points,
allocation of responsibility.
To assure availability,
how do you allocate responsibility?
to have high availability,
determine the system responsibilities,
ensure that additional responsibilities
have been allocated to detect no mission,
crash,
incorrect timing or incorrect response.
So you must have the infrastructure in
place so that you can detect these faults,
these type of
Ohh, activity, and then...
Ensure that this is responsibility,
they should log the fault,
notify appropriate people,
or disable the source of the event,
become temporarily unavailable,
fix or mask, operate in a degraded mode.
These are the type of actions,
preferably you should have a pre...
assigned table which tells you under each
condition what type of action should be
taken.
So this is what we mean by allocation of
responsibility,
that who should take the decision.
What are the alternatives,
under what conditions,
what decision should be taken?
These sort of things will help you.
Maintain the commitment against
availability.
And we have coordination model.
Then.
How do you coordinate between various
subcomponents?
to make sure you get high availability.
What is the mechanism to find the fault?
What is the mechanism for putting systems
out of service?
Do you have some automated mechanism for
masking?
Do you have manual processes?
What type of alarms are raised?
How do various subsystems interact?
Do you have an automated feature to
switch over to a...
A backup storage.
Do you have a mechanism which will repair
the disc which is damaged?
If you have a read array,
how do you go about replacing a
particular disc in the read matrix?
So this type of coordination of the
activity
To assure availability would be.
Decided on data model.
Which data needs to be highly available?
To make it highly available,
what do you do?
Sometimes what we do is that data which
is to be read,
which needs high availability to maintain
multiple copies.
Sometimes you make sure that the data
which is supposed to be available
regularly is you do a vertical splicing
of data and you make sure that you've got
high reliability mirrored units to
provide access to data which is critical.
You might have a system where you cache
your write request in the server,
which becomes temporarily unavailable.
And perform those writes.
When this, when you return to service.
Mapping among architectural limits.
There are,
when we say architectural elements,
The.
we mean...
subsystems, units, storage units,
processing units, communication channels.
How do these elements communicate with
one another and what type of backup
mechanisms you keep there. So
How will you?
Map these units to one another at runtime,
or...
At the...
Design time at build time, so, so that.
Recovery of fault is easy,
or there is a mechanism.
That.
you can shift the responsibility to
another area or communicate suitable
message. So if there's a problem,
can you remap the units such that the
functionality can keep taking place if
you've got,
say you're in a banking environment.
and you got core banking,
all the databases maintained at one place.
Oh.
Do you maintain certain cache at the
branch level so that at least you can see
And then.
the statement up to a particular point,
even if the network is down? Now,
these could be the type of decisions.
So your...
Okay.
online system, it may break down,
it may not allow transaction,
Sure.
If you come, you should come from that.
but it can continue to allow access to
data which is locally available by
remapping the architectural elements.
You may allow transactions up to a
certain limit from an ATM which has
fosters communication beyond.
Yes.
Just.
is local branch.
So any type of mapping between
architectural elements would be decided
by the architect. Resource management,
again a question of...
whether you'll have a load balancer with
multiple servers or you'll have a hot
backup or a warm backup, cold backup.
Whether you'll have...
distributed storage so that to make sure
that availability is there even the event
Okay.
of a network failure at a larger level.
So what will be your resource limitation
to achieve higher availability?
Depending on the type of availability
required, read availability,
write availability, you may.
Take decision on resources. Binding time,
we have discussed in the past.
Late binding or early binding.
Late binding gives you.
Better options,
you can switch between processors,
switch between storages,
but the system becomes more complex.
And the architects takes a decision on
this choice of technology.
What technology do you use to swap?
Hot swap components from your system.
How do you reintroduce components in the
event of a failure?
How do you recover the transaction logs
and apply them before?
Starting an application,
so whether you use event loggers.
what type of,
how do you utilise event loggers to
rebuild your database or your transaction
up to its currency.
These type of decisions are taken as far
as availability is concerned.
Then we come to performance and...
We'll just look at the startup
performance and we'll disconnect.
Next class, I will quickly touch on.
the items covered in to be covered in
today's module.
If there are any clarifications,
I'll answer them,
but I'll continue basically with the next
slide set.
So my request would be to definitely even
to appear for the quiz.
You need to go through these components,
so please do go through them.
And...
But.
I just...
You've got...
Here are the tactics.
These tactics are things which I would
urge that you try to understand the
meaning of each of the tactics.
The quiz will come up sometime tomorrow.
But even if it comes out tomorrow or day
after, it'll be available up to...
Next Saturday, just before this class.
But I will not be taking the class on 8th
August,
but the quiz will stop it on 8th August.
And the next quiz will be after I've
taken the next class.
Right.
There will be a quiz. So,
and every time there's,
even if there are two classes the same
week, you'll get one week for each class.
I will not be able to take the class on
the 8th, right? There'll be no class.
I'll make a formal announcement.
And the adjustment of the class also,
I'll inform it well in advance.
so that at least you can try to attend.
Yeah,
the quiz will be based on topic covered
till today, but in any case,
it's open to all the...
Internet resources and things only think
15 questions in 5 minutes,
Yeah.
so we have to be fairly fast about it,
even if you're using any.
AI tools to answer the question.
It's a fact that people use AI tools,
so I don't want to make a secret of it.
I don't want people to fail only because
they don't do it.
But even if you're using AI tools,
my request will be prepared for the quiz
before taking it by going through the
slides.
Whether it helps you for the quiz or not,
it will at least help you to stay revised
with the course.
Thank you.
So long, good day.
We wish you some enjoyable classes during
Thank you, sir. Hello, sir.
the day. Bye-bye. Bye. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ohh, I.
Thank you.
query, small query. So sir,
I was just going through the course
handout like last time you have mentioned,
right? So like,
I was just trying to understand like,
what are the topics that we would be
Right.
discussing in this course and like,
if I have to create any notes for myself,
like for the exam,
like it's that I'm trying to make a note
for myself.
So that for exam,
I can just refer that one particular
document or something for myself.
So I just like have gone through the
topics that have mentioned on the handout.
And here in class,
like when we are discussing through this
PPTs,
I see more topics that we are discussing
here. So like.
Yeah.
What is that like one thing like I can
properly follow to make any notes for
myself like rather than going to
different thing different books or
Four.
something?
See, both normally, you know,
I would normally be happy discussing this
in the beginning of the class.
At the end of the class is not really
fair to many people who have left,
but still, since you brought it up,
I'll answer your question. You know,
everybody has their own style,
Okay.
and I know that even I used to make a lot
of...
notes when I was a student. This course,
preparing notes,
Mhm.
is going to be a bit difficult because
this course is too vast.
Okay.
Yeah.
So I would suggest if you can take a.
Somehow take a print out with three
slides per page.
Maybe you can take a print out twice,
once now and once for the exam.
Mhm.
Mark up the slides rather than try to
make notes. Because it's too much,
the content is huge.
You'll hardly find enough time to go
through all these 146 slides.
Okay,
and you the course coverage you go by
Okay, so...
slides. Okay,
don't just go handout gives you the broad
Okay, okay.
outline.
It doesn't give you the detail and you'll
Okay.
find that the content of the slides is
actually as per handout,
but the handout is just got the main
headings. Okay, so.
Okay.
OKOK.
And do take me up on this type of
discussion in the beginning of the
Ohh.
session. That will be nice of you. OK,
thank you. Yeah, bye, bye, bye, bye.
Okay, okay. Thank you.
Bye everybody.
Blue.
Sorry, the PDF file is not there.
The PPT is available in the...
In MS TEAMS, in that shared folder,
but you have to make your own PDF if you
Yeah.
feel like.
If you make a PDF,
you can make three or six pages per page
and easy to take a printout.
But that's something I'm not providing.
Okay,
we'll talk about it when we meet next.
Yeah, bye.
Choose 7 small thing.
So.
Yeah, right.
Hi, Sudhishan. So for quiz,
like we have till performance tactics
Yeah.
only, or else complete.
No, no, the full thing, the full slide,
full slide, 146.
Okay, thanks. Yeah.
Please go through the full thing. Yeah.
OK. Bye, bye, bye. Welcome.
Sure, sir, thank you so much.
Hi, sir, myself, Prashanth.
Can you just suggest me the textbook
Yeah.
Yep.
which you are referring for your slide?
Is is is given is given in the course and
out Lenbeth.
Okay, so what I don't know what is it?
Okay, but I'm telling you, yeah,
but what I'll tell you is that it's nice
to have the textbook,
definitely read through it.
But if you are limited on time,
make sure you go through the slides
definitely, okay?
Sure, sir, not good, sir.
So, yeah, yeah.
Thank you, thank you.
Welcome. Bye, bye, bye, bye.
Thank you, sir.
Thank you. Thank you. So long. Bye.